à 16 ans pour moi c'est incroyable c'est
ma première scène j'ai stressé la taille
et
car là ça dépend ce qu'on appelle les
mamans en scène emma émerger ma passion
c'est le rap
morales a
su attendre vu pour le festival vallès
faire une première partie de
grands rappeurs que on écoute
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai l'impression que coach qui
arrange pas du jour j de stresser on va
pas manger avant toi la petite scène
voilà ça me fait pas peur mais la grande
même fait peur à la grande
[Applaudissements]
je veux que le prénom il a émergé sur
leur avis à vie est trop courte
avec les gens se souviennent de moi ça
va toujours
[Applaudissements]
j'ai envie de percer j'ai envie de
réussir donc je vais tout faire peur
[Musique]
salut tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien alors je sais pas si vous
vous rappelez mais à quelques mois
j'avais sorti un reportage sur les
rapports de la zup sud de nîmes pour
celles et ceux qui l'ont pas encore vu
il est disponible juste ici l époque
j'avais rencontré et mac enregistrer des
sons dans un petit studio improvisé de
la zup on perd la foi myth et mon
intérêt chauffeur tchèque entend écouter
les jeunes loups tchatche et j'avoue
j'avais beaucoup aimé son énergie je
suis resté en contact avec elle pour
voir un peu comment elle évolue dans le
monde du rap et quelques semaines et mal
m'a rappelé et en fait elle m'a annoncé
que pour la première fois de sa vie elle
allait monter sur scène devant des
milliers de personnes en première partie
de grands rappeurs très connue alors et
baala que 16 ans elle est en terminale
et elle vit dans un petit village juste
à côté de nîmes et du coup avec brut on
a décidé de la suivre pour ce moment
crucial de son tout début de carrière de
rappeuse
alors là ici on dans le coeur de
marguerite
c'est moi j'habite ici je suis fier
ouais marguerittes dans mes textes est
important c'est pour ça que je fais un
abrégé émerger et d'où mon nom de scène
emma immergé
j'ai vécu avec ma mère jusqu'à mes onze
ans dans un petit appartement mes
parents ils sont séparés depuis que j'ai
deux ans c'est ma mère qui m'a éduqué
c'est mes grands parents aussi qui m'ont
éduqué puis côté de ma mère depuis tout
petit mais depuis tout petit j'aime la
musique c'est à dire je regardais pas et
dessins animés quand j'étais petit je
regardais toujours les clips de musique
toujours je connaissais toujours les
chansons par coeur de sexion d'assaut
tout ça ça a commencé
petite soirée tranquille on mettait des
instruments
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
monzée de rap et comme je peux je
connais pas je connais pas les bases et
ça a été mis sur les réseaux je me
notamment sur snap unis
[Musique]
on va faire la vaisselle sur elle mais
des caleçons c est mahomet dit va faire
la vaisselle ou suce moi comme tu veux
help is debout ares sa malheureusement
je peux pas je suis désolé
ouais j'ai beaucoup de bas faire la
vaisselle beaucoup
[Musique]
même pas c'est une fille qui m'avait
toujours un garçon manqué donc qui rappe
ça bien pour son manque et en plus je
peux te dire que là tu es prêt pour le
bad buzz ou le buzz tout ce que tu veux
c'est beaucoup les hommes qui me
critiquent on dirait qu'ils ont là et
aussi beaucoup de critiques tout ce qui
est religieux tout le monde croit que je
suis musulmane ou que j'ai une religion
alors que je n'ai pas du tout de
religion passe en piste une critique je
vais faire des choses moi y'a pas de
soucis
au moins la casse des portes et skyrock
j'avais envoyé un prix ce talk avec buzz
et en février 2021 m'ont appelé m'ont
dit emma écoute pas ce matin mère l'a
gagné le concours il faut remonter à
planète rap j'ai pas dormi de la nuit
j'étais stressé jamais monte à paris
grâce à la musique je voyage
on monte le son en tacot va c'est une
instru mélancolique traîne avec tout le
monde mais n'inquiète pas les faut que
j'évite titre 3 à dire pour une jeune
fille qui connaît pas la bi mais pape a
vécu dans l'ailleurs donc j'ai des
choses à dire avant tout j'ai vite pas
là badji vite les gens comme toi ceux
qui souhaitent la réussite et quand
c'est du n'importe quoi et je représente
et nîmes émerger tu connais les buy 6
juin sky c'est pas pour la péter mais
pour faire du sale c'est un rêve monter
à skyrock en tant que style
bien ce tag ram tout le monde de passer
par là on dit cela relève de diam's
alors que je suis la petite nouvelle je
suis là pour mettre les pendules à
l'heure je suis là pour tous les fers
type tu veu râpé comment ça n'a fait que
se prête pas me faire un concert dans
les arènes de nîmes alléluia se bat dans
le ghetto car chez moi il y en a pas
citron la dalle tu promets aux anciens
que la whey ces matières et du bape ont
émergé
il est bien de parler après s'il n'y a
pas là ma mère mon beau-père et la tuque
est conçu comme ça et bah voilà bravo
n'a
représenté
que ça déchire et jamais de ma vie déjà
16 ans
j'ai jamais cru que j'allais monter à
skyrock
ça vous inquiète moi je peut se fier que
surpris parce que je savais que ça
allait finir comme ça puisqu'elle n'a
pas lâché et est obligé qu'elle
réussisse ses fans naïfs croient que
grâce à ton juste est-ce que tu
travailles si elle se retrouve à skyrock
c'est ce retrait ouvre la caméra de brut
j'ai besoin de raisons je sais pas
mais moi tant que ça à dire ton parcours
qu'est ce qu'on s'en fait un avis en
retz à un vrai de vrai un bris de vrij
souffert sans mentir je suis bien
non non c'est bon les gars ce truand
lever la casquette
[Musique]
et
obi gif
c'est un truc de fous les uns que vous
aviez pas faire ça mais
je m'en allais oublier tout mon passé
recommencer je me taille de ces visites
je n'arrive plus excuse moi je suis
désolé
c'est clair
c'est en fait c'est tout le truc deuil
et de demain ça que je serais ce
que les arènes et ils peuvent accueillir
3500 personnes ce qui est déjà énorme
pour moi non franchement j'ai
l'impression se fait clairement j'ai pas
bien je crois bien
concert de mercredi notamment
réfléchissez deux minutes métier
bourgi arènes d'alès ça va craquer mais
encore tranquille quoi que la loi
tranquille vers 5e alors ça y est là on
y est là bonjour alors moi je connais
pas trop je passe mon cher
alors moi ouais j'ai la paix d'alger
tout en fait j micro micro pas besoin ok
le régler mais voilà mais
ça peut-être alors exactement je sais
pas comment
c'est abusé ok tu vas en famille
franchement je vais faire le dernier pas
loin juste en cause et non
ah ouais parrot les micros pour éviter
de le tenir par l'abonné
je suis pas prêt proches fait ça alors
qu'il ya un mois j'étais tranquille un
ouais j'ai faire ça je vais passer là
et c'est que le début ça va être remplie
au pur et elle a dû rendre à sa mère ça
bouge suis pas je suis bien mais je suis
pas de lyon
ça montrait marche pas
voix
ce que j'aimerais trop arrêté le temps
parce que là je ne sais pas
n'est pas prêt
[Applaudissements]
on s'en relève ça allait bien
ok
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ici aussi bonne équipe
[Musique]
c'est dj nul mais tu écoutes
les gens
dans ton corps c'est à tes émotions
d'atouts fait la joie de la bonne humeur
à tout tout tout franchement je suis
trop contente j'ai de la chance de vivre
ce moment des faits
[Musique]
non
à
mensonge
il ya ma famille ma mère elle vient ont
beau père aussi mes grands parents aussi
presque tout le monde je fais tout pour
rendre fiers mes proches et ma mère
cette musique à elle est pour tous les
géniteurs de france l'éducation avant le
thème
respect comme une proie trop coûteux
verra trompeta mère qui l'a fait
aucunement taux d'épargné à lui dit je
donne s'inverse et c'est un gros c'est
ça une famille si j'avais pas ma mère
alors aujourd'hui je pouvais crier
famine se fait qu'à une gamme de sept
ans quand on perd et non plus au fun
vous restez ma grand mère qui venait me
chercher après l'école parce que ma mère
se trouvait plus arrosée dans x années
du marathon mais des baisses après que
pour moi je suis pas quelqu'un qui
m'exprime c'est à dire je garde tout en
moi et c'est grâce aussi ils ont rappelé
que
j'arrive à à défoncer des portes à dire
ce que j'ai à dieu
réfléchissant fois dans ma chance c'est
voilà avec eux je voulais moi
fruits
à genoux tout est là
quand j'écris un texte avait le coeur
c'est l'émotion en promet beaucoup mais
j'ai déjà pleuré ce que j'écris un son
bien sûr
je me suis en droit jean majeau c'est
pas la foulée
[Musique]
avec moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et moi tu fais tu pour les bergers
bizier
[Applaudissements]
nickel
on l'a fait on l'a fait
[Musique]
coucou ou la vie wallonne
du contentement après ce concert et
maeva reprendre le lycéen comme tout le
monde à la rentrée et d'ailleurs il ya
plusieurs labels qu'ils ont déjà appelé
mais préfère finir de passer son bac
avant de signer quoi que ce soit
j'espère que vous avez aimé ce reportage
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à liker a commenté à partager et
si vous êtes apprécié ce type de
reportage que vous aimez qu'on met en
lumière des profils comme emma n'hésitez
pas à nous de mettre en commentaire je
vous dis à très bientôt et au revoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ouais c'est mon énergie à jacques
dallest et merci
[Musique]